combien de sex com c'est un cri d'alarmé
qui résonne dans les rues de lyon
plusieurs centaines d'étudiants se sont
rassemblés ce jeudi pour faire entendre
leur détresse après que deux d'entre eux
ont tenté de se suicider au cours du
mois de janvier
privés de cours depuis près de deux mois
à cause de la situation sanitaire
les élèves se considèrent comme les
oubliés de cette crise soumis à la
précarité à l'isolément
il réclame à présent des actions
concrètes aujourd'hui on adapte
simplement parce que on est en situation
difficile pour les étudiants sur le plan
psychologique elle sur le plan
financières et beaucoup d'étudiants qui
sont en galère qui n'en peuvent plus qui
veulent pouvoir retourner à l'université
qui peuvent tuer le pouvoir avoir les
moyens de pouvoir étudier convenablement
nous la couverture des facultés en
hybridation avec une plateforme en ligne
qui fonctionne et on veut pas que
de voir l'enseignement supérieur c'est
cool et même la précarité financière
augmente et donc voilà c'est pour ça
qu'on est là aujourd'hui pour que les
universités ou avec le gouvernement la
tête face au raz le bol de plus en plus
audible emmanuel macron a pris la parole
ce jeudi dans l'essonne au cours d'un
déplacement sur un campus universitaire
le président a notamment annoncé la mise
en place d'un programme de repas à 1
euro pour tous les étudiants boursiers
ou non
autres revendications évoquées par le
chef de l'état la réouverture des
universités
un étudiant qui soit en licence au
master une étudiante
il doit avoir à peu près les mêmes
droits et les mêmes besoins quelqu'un
qui travaille et s'il en a besoin et
doit pouvoir revenir une journée par
semaine à l'université pour faire du
présentiel que ce soit en td ou en cours
et donc ce qu'on va construire c'est une
solution pour le deuxième semestre qui
consistera à dire un étudiant une
étudiante a le droit d'avoir 20 % de son
temps en présentiel et on doit essayer
de tenir c'est à dire un jour sur cinq
et on doit essayer de tenir aussi pour
que les jauges comme on dit ce terme est
affreux mais que ce soit jamais plus de
20% face à la détresse psychologique qui
semble gagner de plus en plus de jeunes
emmanuel macron a confirmé la création
d'un chèque psy qui permettra de pouvoir
consulter un psychologue et suivre des
soins
mais la sortie de crise semble encore
bien loin
le chef de l'état a prévenu que le
retour à la normale ne se ferait pas
avant la rentrée de septembre 2021